we live in a world characterized by
overwhelming environmental challenges we
must try to tackle the effects of global
warming the problems created by birth
overpopulation and overconsumption and
the depletion of natural resources how
can we best manage our consumption and
utilization of our Earth's natural
resources and protect our environment to
answer this and other related questions
we constantly need to be aware of the
state and health of our planet
the Copernicus program helps us to
achieve this by observing our
environment collecting storing and
analyzing data and providing products to
enable effective decisions to be made
brought together by different
stakeholders in the European Union
Copernicus monitors our planet and its
many ecosystems while ensuring that its
inhabitants are prepared for and
protected against crises and natural or
man-made disasters
Copernicus information services are
based on data from a constellation of
six families of satellites known as the
sentinels and dozens of third party
satellites known as contributing space
missions these measuring devices in
orbit
sometimes operate alone and sometimes
combined with sensors placed on the sees
land or in the air
Copernicus then stores the data and
helps to provide a large amount of
reliable and up-to-date information on
the status of our planet this data can
be used to create different kinds of
products such as statistics and
topographic maps the data is analyzed in
a way that generates indicators useful
for researchers and end-users providing
information on past present and future
trends Copernicus contributes not only
to European scientific and technical
excellence but is part of a public
service framework allowing full free and
open access to all data collected anyone
scientists policymakers entrepreneurs
and ordinary citizens can use this data
its missions also include essential
interrelated themes incorporating six
sets of services atmosphere monitoring
marine environment monitoring land
monitoring climate change emergency
management and security that translate
into concrete and effective areas of
application with regards to the
environment
Copernicus detects the content of
aerosols that destroys the ozone layer
analyzing atmospheric composition and
biodiversity it is regularly evaluating
the melting of the polar ice cap in the
Arctic as a result of temperature
increases due to global warming
it determines the quality of air and
water that affects our health it wants
us ocean levels coastal areas and
forests in order to limit the damage
from the threat of earthquakes floods
and fires to ensure our safety in the
energy sector
Copernicus promotes the use of hydraulic
and wind power plants promising clean
eco-friendly alternatives to fossil
fuels this will allow for renewable
energy to account for up to 27% of our
total energy consumption by 2030
Copernicus also supports the monitoring
of the external borders of the European
Union using space data merged with other
sources of information to increase
situational awareness and improve
assessment of risk at the external
borders serving the marine world
Copernicus tracks marine pollution
affecting aquatic ecosystems and the
fishing industry as part of a
development cooperation policy
Copernicus warns of early signs of
deforestation and desertification
in order to avoid the problems of loss
of biodiversity and food shortages it
oversees the irrigation of fields and
monitors crops for better food
management it is also instrumental in
tracing outbreaks of diseases such as a
bowler in West Africa further to these
examples
Copernicus conserve the tourism industry
urban development archaeology oil and
gas fund the insurance sector it is an
incredible tool efficient constantly
evolving open to all and free of charge
and this will always be the case
it is a tool to create new applications
new opportunities new markets new jobs
independent studies indicate that by
2030 nearly 48 thousand jobs could be
created by the application of copernicus
and why not tens of thousands of users
already make use of the data which is
freely available knowing that each euro
invested in satellite technology
represents a high return on investment
the number of business opportunities is
likely to increase in the coming years
New Horizons are coming ever closer to
us here on earth and in space